was very gracious when he came on our
show he was talking about how you taught
him how to write comedy at SNL like you
showed him how to do a proper script and
all of that and he was I could tell he
really is grateful for that and admires
your talent he was you know when he
showed up at SNL what I remember is that
can be a grim place just because there's
so much pressure and it can be
competitive he showed up and he was the
most
enthusiastic young kid and just isn't
this awesome we're here at SNL this is
the best that's and and Adam always says
this is the buddy this is the best so
you could go to an IHOP and get a very
mediocre pancake oh buddy this is the
best and he was just so I I I drafted
off of his enthusiasm and energy uh and
a lot of us did he was just it's all
good can you believe we're here isn't
this amazing and I love that